foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
happy Thursday everyone well it's day
eight without cat on the show as you
know she's on her honeymoon I think she
sent us a video
hey Greg I'm still on my honeymoon I'm
in Germany and I know I always laughed
you talked about all the movies you made
here in the 90s but you're actually
Super Famous here everyone keeps telling
me how much they missed their dirty
Hasselhoff
it's true it took me three years to get
the stench out
anyway do you feel you're being primed
for something like the UFC does for
weeks before their next big pay-per-view
the media is trying to gear us up for
the ultimate showdown between Biden and
Trump fighting out of the Red Corner
with a record of one and one standing
six foot three 245 pounds hailing from
Mar-A-Lago Florida by way of NYC Donald
the disrupter Trump and fighting out of
the blue corner with a record of 50
years of mistakes and two years of
embarrassment standing six feet tall
napping at three feet tall and weighing
in at 180 pounds depending on his last
bow movement oh God
Joe the demented old circus monkey Biden
[Laughter]
see how fair and balanced that was talk
about a build up right you got January
6th theater then you got the raid and
all the phony stories that followed
first it was the nuke Secrets then it
was empty folders what's next did he
take the office hole puncher oh my God
that's a nickname for Amarosa
I don't even know what it means
what that means sure you don't I don't
okay then came Joe's speech fascism
Civil War a blood red backdrop that
would give Dracula the Willies but if
you forgot here's a clip
[Applause]
thank you
of course Trump makes a perfect
distraction it's like when Cavuto wears
bike shorts to a funeral
every metric reveals fan
of left-wing policies why
Why Try to deflect to the guy who tracks
cameras like me getting out of a limo in
a micro skirt
yeah you're thinking about it though
that's all I want I want you to go home
and think about it
pretending not to but the media wants
Trump back and why not let's compare the
last two presidents Putin's
kleptographic yeah
kleptocracy Club the guys who are the
kleptocracies that Runway is like an ice
skating rink
and the first step I said you know this
sucker is slippery
I think it was put in by the Democrats
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
and I thought that was the sun in my
eyes it's these stupid lights these
people
I mean what are we what are they doing
that's my little sister Valerie and I'm
Jill's husband oh no oh you switched on
me the light's no good I always look
orange
and so do you
bro no wonder they missed the guy
so maybe it's time to ask ourselves do
we miss him too right because remember
he causes serious emotional responses in
people he's like the human version of
chasing a cigarette with a large black
coffee you know you get nervous your
heart starts beating and you start
looking for a toilet
I have friends that can't talk about him
without physically changing just check
out my neighbor Steve when I mentioned
Trump
yes
I imagine this is how my exes feel
whenever they see me on TV
it's okay we all won
but this is what I tell
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know what it means again
but this is what I tell never trumpers
no one says you have to like the person
who works for you and when Trump's
president he's working for you just like
a doctor a garbage man or if you're
Hunter a hooker
Trump's our nation's waiter hi my name
is Donald and I'll be your server for
tonight this evening's specials are Law
and Order building a wall and laughing
at the losers and haters
fact is people who make your life better
they can suck if I had to undergo
emergency surgery I don't need to like
the doctor I take a great Doctor Who's a
straight up a-hole over a Charming
handsome fella who removes the wrong
kidney
or forgets to put in the one I bought
off eBay
so yeah I'll take Dr Jekyll over Dr Jill
oh
after all once fictional and the other
is Dr Jekyll
[Applause]
funny
people tend to be relentless and rude
right
and if people hate Trump that's good
because chances are they hate him
because he really works for you and
makes them work hard too plus he scares
people is that so bad I want my doctor
lawyer agent astrologist to be feared
because that means they don't take no
for an answer if you're a pro athlete
come contract negotiation time do you
want Don Knotts or Don Rickles Trump
might have been a prick when he was out
for himself but when he transferred that
energy to us well that's magic think
about why Biden's been around forever
he's not looking out for you he was
always out for himself he didn't lead he
cut self-serving deals the way his son
Cuts lines of Coke
thick but what did Trump used to say
I will never ever let you down I will
never ever let you down I will never let
you down I will never let you down I
promise you that so why did he mean that
it's because of the desires for his
success mapped directly onto yours but
to never trumpers he feels like their
scariest boss well behind Kamala but
their error their mistake is assuming
that they're beholden to Trump when it's
the opposite he's not your boss he works
for you and you want a monster like him
working for you at all times of course
there is a price he's like Mike Tyson
there was nothing like him in the ring
but something so relentless can't be
turned off the fight goes on after the
Bell is rung like after an election when
the bell rang Trump kept fighting
that's part of the deal sorry so do you
want some energy monster that's on your
side or some backslapping semi-ly
congenial bureaucrat who will tell you
to relax when your gas bill doubles and
you can't afford meat in a few months
Joe's going to change the definition of
food and force you to eat bugs
so unless you need a fourth for
shuffleboard you don't need Joe
that's a choice the brainless napping
mutt you have now or the pit bull
waiting in the wings
I say you need the dog the media hates
because he won't do what they say he
does what you say sure every once in a
while this Pit Bull is going to take a
dump on the rug but
but that's all he has in common with
Biden
[Applause]
she traded cheerleading for law because
there's way less spelling outnumbered
co-host Emily compagno
these appeared on more panels than
pressure treated plywood Fox News
contributor in Washington Times opinion
editor Charlie Hurts So Good
this school choice activist puts bad
teachers in detention senior fellow at
the American Federation for children or
Equity Corey DeAngelis
and he makes Hercules question his
masculinity my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Television Champion
Charlie I want to go to you first I've
had enough Emily ah
yeah you know I always try when I have
these conversations with people that
that are just scared you know of trump
returning I go like if you just reframe
him from being a dangerous arrogant
arrogant monster to being your dangerous
arrogant monster then he becomes like
the best president ever you know he's
like having a big giant doberman on a
chain that you can barely control yeah
you know he's like like your plumber you
don't want you you don't want a clean
plumber you want a plumber that gets the
plumbing fixes the problem what a dirty
plumber you want and and
nope
a bodyguard you want a bodyguard
this he's he's more like a
bodyguardy really dirty shirtless maybe
Mike Rowe goodbye bodyguard be Mike Rowe
Uncle I give up I'm sorry keep going I
apologize no but a jerk but it's no but
it's really important uh because the the
truth you know they call him an
extremist and the reason they call him
an extremist is because he's the least
extreme president we've ever had and the
and and both parties are terrified of
him obviously more so Democrats than
Republicans but when you think about it
Donald Trump is the most unifying
President we have ever had when it comes
to the issues if you're talking about
the Border if you're talking about
energy Independence or you're talking
about the economy
60 70 80 90 percent of Americans agree
with him on those issues but because of
his style and because the media is so
distorted so much about his the issues
they've been able to portray him as this
this go ahead I know and and and and
it's a complete lie it's a total lie and
if if people would just focus on the
issues and say he's the plumber that's
going to fix the problem or he's The
Bodyguard that's going to fix the
problem he's like an 80 guy yeah exactly
and the problem is there's that the
emotional component and it's like I I
actually have friends that admit that
it's an emotional response yes right
that they're like okay and so I always
say Emily that he's like a three-hour
drive to an hour at the beach right it's
expensive to get what you want with with
Trump what do you say to that young lady
yeah I think you know you can you can
serve and Lead at the same time and
that's what we saw in president Trump
and that's the opposite of what we're
seeing in President Biden and I I feel
that so deeply because I was a federal
attorney for so long that I never lost
sight of the fact that I was a steward
of everyone's money and my salary and
time and whatnot Stuart desk
the flight attendant of everyone's time
and money
um and you know I don't forget that oh I
can't say that I don't forget that to
President Biden we are the enemy yes to
President Biden the only reason that
that Trump is now back in his crosshairs
is because somehow whoever writes his
speeches have moved on from the average
American that flies the flag in their
front yard and cares about their
children's education and cares about
policy and and crime being diminished
and cities being safe and the Border
being secure those were the enemy before
and I haven't forgotten that and all of
The Independents haven't forgotten that
either because those polls still reflect
that Independence in droves are going to
vote for the GOP in November so they can
put the red backgrounds all they want
they can become Carrie part two but no
one's going to forget that they were the
ones that were top of Biden's enemy list
before he circled back to president
Trump not bad for stewardess
can I be a stewardess too
you can
I identify as a stewardess there you go
what do you um perhaps more water yeah
do you get a little paranoid that the
Dems want Trump because they think they
can beat him they really want him to go
up against Biden I think Joe Biden wants
to be more like Trump and if you look at
his Independence Day speech Emily
mentioned that the speech writers a
little bit ago and I really think that
we've all been duped that these speech
writers are actually undercover agents
for the Republican party because it was
just so far out there his Independence
Day speech with the red behind him he
had the Marines behind him it was so
divisive and it's so funny coming from
the same person who ran on being the
unifier of the country he's taken quite
the opposite turn and it's not going to
work out for him in November it I will
say that it is effective Tyrus because I
feel like it's I mean there's some
polling that shows that it you know that
mag is scary to them do you think that
Biden's going to face him
I I don't know if Biden's gonna face
anyone
um you know he might be laying on the
ground while he's running but here's the
thing if you turned off your social
media and mainstream media for a month
when President Trump was in office
you would see that your check was better
your bills were better and your
neighborhoods were safe right right as
soon as you turned on the TV that's when
the hysteria started because what was
big president Trump's biggest problem he
was uncorruptable because he had it
already he didn't need their money he
didn't need their influence and had no
problem putting them on blast let's
remember at one point he was a Democrat
who was cutting checks for who Democrats
so who knows them better than the guy
who's cutting checks for them he did and
that was the issue so he if you didn't
look at the first world hysteria his
deeds were pretty good the problem was
with the pit bull is Trump is probably
the the greatest worst first responder
of all time yeah as soon as you throw
shade he's coming back at you they threw
a disc he would fight back exactly so
they would that would be what everyone
saw and we would forget about the Deeds
now we miss the Deeds because or not
just the gasoline prices and this is how
they get us they brought them down a
dollar but everyone who got electric
bill saw them make up the difference
when your electric bill is tripled and
sometimes are quadrupled so that's but
they brought it down that's the
difference if he wasn't such a first
responder and who knows maybe he's you
know maybe the put a little muzzle on
him a little bit but other than that his
deeds outweighed the bots on Twitter all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else